à présent nous sommes en ligne avec
Alona shroom bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous êtes une
députée ukrainienne membre du parti
Union pas ukrainienne patrie dans quel
état d'esprit êtes-vous aujourd'hui fier
de la résistance de votre pays convaincu
que vous allez l'emporter
mais bien sûr parce que
hier dans le même temps le même temps le
même après midi et bien sûr que
il y a une année nous ne pensons pas que
on ne peut vraiment avoir toutes les
soutiens que on a eu de de partir de la
France de tous de tous les États
démocratiques de tout le monde et nous
nous
aimons ça me fait très très seul nous
pensons que nous restons seuls avec la
Russie avec la dictateur avec une armée
trop grande avec une pays très grande
dans cette dans cette gare horrible mais
maintenant nous connaissons très bien
que nous ne sommes pas seuls que il y a
beaucoup beaucoup des amis qui ne
soutiennent il y a beaucoup de pays qui
ne soutiennent et bien sûr que c'est une
année de résistance c'est une année de
de choses que nous avons fait vraiment
quelque chose que que apparaissait
impossible il est possible et maintenant
c'est
une autre une autre espoir que on peut
gagner
et on peut le faire cette année parce
que les Ukrainiens vraiment vraiment de
la paix et pour avoir la paix durable il
faut que une des parties gagne ce guerre
et bien sûr que ce ne peut pas être la
Russie qui = ce garçon doit être le
crâne